c'est un personnage emblématique du
paysage audiovisuel français il a
commencé à France Télévisions il a
couvert des Jeux Olympiques quelle
patinage artistique la commenter avant
de devenir évidemment l'un des visages
et des voix les plus connus de la
télévision française Nelson Monfort va
nous rejoindre sur ce plateau on va
peut-être voir un extrait parce que il
est beaucoup venu Cyril l'aime beaucoup
mais sur la tête je kiffe ta tenue on
dirait le prof d'histoire mon frère
je pense
qu'on peut baisser son micro
eh Nelson sur la tête de ma mère on
dirait que tu vas jouer dans barre de
billes et vous venez nous voir d'abord
avant tout pour le Mondial de la veste
hein bien sûr
donc il démarre dans deux semaines elle
est pas belle
on a du cache mais on a du bleu roulisse
on a bien sûr de l'alcantara juste ici
ce qu'on avait pas avant regardez alors
ici il est surpiqûres on les avait pas
sur la saison 2013 hein tu vois la
saison 2014
je connais la marque ça c'est le Vieux
Campeur ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
britannique
[Rires]
alors qui qui veut proposer
on va laisser Jean-Luc proposer c'est
lui qui a la meilleure élocution
[Rires]
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a eu des bons souvenirs
[Rires]
[Musique]
votre votre carrière vos débuts à la
télévision à la télévision française
France Télévisions et puis vous allez
commenter aussi des Jeux Olympiques
2024 Nelson Monfort vous avez commenté
aussi d'athlétisme vous n'arrêtez jamais
Nelson de fort je vais dire que juste je
vais en profiter pour parler de votre
livre parce que il y a aussi un livre
qui s'appelle mémoire olympique est
actuellement disponible aux éditions
Michel Lafont et puis vous êtes au
théâtre avec Philippe Candeloro dans la
pièce sa patine à Tokyo qui est
actuellement en répétition puis au
Festival d'Avignon voilà l'affiche ça
promet ça promet d'être seulement fort
tiens d'ailleurs bonjour Philippe
cornello
Philippe Candeloro je sais pas si vous
nous entendez comment ça va
merci d'être avec nous bonjour
la connexion est-elle
ça va très bien en fait quand vous allez
chez vous
la connexion est pas terrible
il doit être à Tokyo où va se passer là
la pièce écrite par un très joli tandem
d'auteur Hugo cremaski et Julien grange
et je crois que je crois que ça va être
un joli moment ici j'ai l'impression que
c'est la joie de vivre qui prédomine sur
ce bateau
de faire à partir de l'année prochaine
effectivement et sans doute un
certainement même au Festival d'Avignon
2024 et puis vous connaissez bien avec
Philippe Candeloro vous formez un duo
aussi un peu emblématique vous avez
commenté le patinage artiste vous avez
fait plein de choses ensemble oui
Philippe m'a souvent même rejoint sur je
rejoins sur scène notamment sur mon
spectacle Georges Brassens avec l'ami
carateau et puis c'est un Schuman et
puis c'est vrai que je pense qu'on a
établi un duo en tant que patinage qui
je pense c'est lui des téléspectateurs
il est celui à la fois techniquement
pour le pour le patinage et puis je
pense j'espère humainement je pense
qu'avec lui et je pense qu'on était
super ça qu'on va passer un bon moment
en tout cas moi c'est ce que j'essaye de
faire et si on en prend pardon par
certains sondage j'ai l'impression que
voilà que que il y a encore peut-être
dans la vie à l'écran
nous avons nous avons chacun nos
itinéraires pas ensemble 24 heures sur
mais oui je pense que c'est un joli
tordais mais c'est vrai qu'on partage
pas mal de mêmes passions on a peut-être
un extrait à avoir avec je connais bien
je faisais partie de cette émission je
m'en souviens très bien
parce que j'adore les les sports de
glisse
[Rires]
si je te dis on vient d'en parler il y a
un instant si je te dis Nelson Monfort
tu me dis ne me parles plus de ce
connard ne parle plus de ce connard
ça a été dur avec lui il a baisé ma
femme je peux en parler il a baisé ma
femme je peux plus en parler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je tiens je tiens à dire que ce n'est
pas vrai
[Rires]
c'était le défi à chaque émission qui
disent les pires horreurs à l'oreille de
l'invité et qui devait de du coup bah le
dire à quelqu'un de proche c'est très
drôle voilà et Nelson Monfort aussi
évidemment on vous connaît
je sais même pas si on va le préciser
mais enfin vous êtes le visage le visage
de l'interviewer des sportifs après leur
performance vous parlez vous êtes
polyglotte et c'est ça aussi qui a fait
votre votre succès c'est comme ça qu'on
vous a conduit c'est certainement comme
ça que les Français vous identifiez mais
c'est quoi votre secret pour passer
d'une langue allô vous précipitez aller
recueillir les je crois déjà depuis le
début de mon itinéraire si vous voulez
je n'ai pas voulu être un interprète
sinon on ferait appel à un interprète
professionnel de l'ONU ou que ça en
revanche j'ai voulu être un passeur
d'émotion ça oui alors les émotions
elles peuvent être positives puis
parfois elles peuvent être un peu moins
positive là nous étions récemment au
championnat du monde
d'athlétisme à Budapest jusqu'à il y a
une dizaine de jours et c'est vrai que
pour les Français ça c'est moyennement
passé donc j'ai pas voulu que ce soit un
bureau des pleurs je voulais je voulais
également consoler vous savez je pense
que les plus beaux souvenirs que j'ai
c'est probablement juste parce que la
victoire tout le monde peut s'en réjouir
tout le monde est heureux etc en
revanche consoler mais il faut que ça il
faut que ça sonne juste parce que ça
soit sincère c'est ce sont des souvenirs
très forts et j'espère que pour certains
d'être français qui sont vraiment
devenus des amis que ça se passera mieux
dans un an pour les JO de Paris ce que
ce que j'espère est-ce que je pense ça
c'est sûr ça c'est sûr
le secret pour devenir polyglotte
paternelle puisque mon père était
citoyen américain je parlais en fait
anglais à la maison avec avec mes
parents ma mère d'origine néerlandaise
et mon père américain il parlait anglais
entre eux donc j'étais bercé dans la
langue de Shakespeare voilà c'est ça
mais c'est une des explications et vous
en parler d'autre vous en parler lorsque
je vous fais une petite confidence pour
m'adresser parfois aux téléspectateurs
j'essaye de déjà de parler un peu plus
doucement surtout de prendre un tout
petit accent français comme ça on me
comprend davantage je vais vous dire
exactement
mais ce qui vous arrive est-ce qu'il
vous arrive de ne pas comprendre les
réponses aux questions que vous posez
parce que parfois on a des accents aussi
assez curieux lorsque vous interrogez
alors je vais vous dire effectivement
les oui c'est arrivé les athlètes des
hauts plateaux vous savez Kenya antiopie
qui se trouve être en plus de
remarquable coureur à à partir du 5000
mètres c'est vrai que parfois j'ai un
peu de mal mais je crois que le contexte
général je le comprends et puis je
dirais que bon je suis persuadé d'une
chose les gens sentent quand on les aime
moi il se trouve que quand je reçois un
athlète éthiopien ou kenyant des hauts
plateaux qui vivent parfois dans des
conditions plus difficiles que nous je
suis tout de suite un coup de cœur
formidable pour ces gens-là je crois que
les gens sentent quand on les aime à
partir de là si la traduction n'est pas
exactement littérale je ne sais pas vous
êtes d'accord avec moi
c'est important voilà les filles qu'on
est l'euro est avec nous par téléphone
parce que ça ne capte pas vous êtes un
Philippe mais ça capte très très mal oui
parfois j'ai du mal à comprendre ce
qu'il me dit je sais pas
une bonne chose votre meilleur souvenir
avec Nelson il y en a pas justement
c'est ça le pire
trop Philippe
ils arrivent ils arrivent les meilleurs
souvenirs avec avec cette pièce de
théâtre pour laquelle Philippe est très
motivé et moi aussi voilà il peut pas
comprendre ce que je lui raconte de
temps en temps puisqu'il ne l'ai jamais
parlé il parle beaucoup plus fort et
beaucoup plus longtemps pour laquelle il
m'a surnommé pour une fois pour toute
Nelson Monfort mets le son moins fort
c'est ce que j'essaye de faire mais
Philippe a fait beaucoup de progrès il
m'a payé un coca light il y a quelques
années déjà et là je le taquine pas mal
parce que c'est pas vrai c'est un des
garçons les plus généreux que je
connaisse et là et là je suis sérieux
à l'antenne ça marche bien qu'est-ce que
c'est que ça fonctionne tous les deux
Philippe
déjà ça va se payer sur scène Nelson
tout ce que tu racontes là on va faire
de l'improvisation sans cette
sanctionner
[Rires]
c'est ma signature après des fois ça
peut déraper c'est sûr mais ce qui fait
le succès je pense de nous deux c'est
que bon on se connaît bien et on va
surtout se protéger l'un et l'autre
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui avec le
mytho on peut plus vraiment en parler
comme on était avant donc en fait
je sais pas parce qu'en fait il y a
beaucoup de
gens de beaucoup plus libre avant sans
vraiment choqué parce que nous on n'est
pas là pour choquer les gens ou dire du
mal des gens on est là pour détendre
l'atmosphère dans un milieu parfois un
peu trop feutré qui est le patinage
si nous avons contribué à moderniser un
petit peu cette discipline qui vous
savez était autrefois un peu avec des
jabaux Henri III vous savez des valses
de Vienne un petit peu avec des couleurs
très très vives etc je pense que
Philippe et moi avons avant moteur déjà
les patineurs en fait mais je pense que
nous avons trouvé à moderniser cette
cette discipline qui est aujourd'hui
suivie par le plus grand nombre vraiment
le patinage
avec vous exactement et avec et avec
Philippe merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous Philippe Candeloro merci
beaucoup et bon courage
[Rires]
la scène ça pardonne pas ça pardonne pas
je voulais aussi qu'on revienne sur une
une séquence et c'est très intéressant
de vous avoir Nelson aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau c'est patrick Montel qui était
sur le plateau de TPMP il y a la semaine
dernière la semaine dernière et qui
montait au créneau en disant c'est
inadmissible alors il a été licencié de
France Télévisions et il dit voilà c'est
inadmissible en fait il était vraiment
très triste parce qu'il ne pourrait pas
il n'a pas de créditation pour commenter
les Jeux Olympiques 2024 je vous propose
qu'on revoit cette séquence et ce serait
intéressant d'avoir votre votre regard
lorsque l'on a un certain âge on est bon
à mettre à la poubelle en France alors
moi je te dis ça oui parce que je le
pense sincèrement je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a un vrai problème
avec l'âge c'est qu'on juge les gens non
pas sur leur compétences non pas sur ce
qu'ils peuvent apporter à une entreprise
mais on les juge aussi sur leur état
civil et ça c'est juste insupportable
alors Michel Drucker est toujours là
Nelson Monfort aussi et je m'en réjouis
je m'en réjouis
la dernière phrase est très confrère
donc je peux pas je peux pas ajouter
grand-chose je suis d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire avec ce que vient de dire
Patrick et bien je crois avoir je crois
avoir compris parce que j'ai suivi cette
émission que Cyril avait une promesse
pour lui donc je sais pas exactement de
quoi il s'agisse mes connaissant le cœur
de Cyril je suis sûr que ça ne sera pas
une promesse de gascon oui voilà mais il
parle de de l'âge il a 70 ans il dit on
est jeté à la poubelle c'est pas votre
cas vous allez commenter les Jeux
Olympiques 2024
chacun est différent moi je j'apprécie
beaucoup ce que vient dire Patrick et
j'espère que je pense et je suis sûr
qu'il retrouvera une antenne pour 2024
et peut-être au-delà merci beaucoup à
Nelson on va répondre aux questions du
PAF après des questions des
téléspectateurs une question peut-être
qui va s'afficher sur votre écran il
nous reste peu de temps
votre compétence
qui vous pose cette question vous avez
une anecdote à raconter sur votre
collaboration avec Cyril dans le tennis
club est-ce que vous en souvenez pas
faire trop long je m'en suis un très
bien et d'ailleurs je sais que s'en
souvient aussi d'ailleurs j'en suis
persuadé qu'il s'en souvient parce que
avant de vous rejoindre j'allais
rencontrer et on a tu parlais un peu de
ce formidable souvenir où nous recevions
donc chaque matin sur la terrasse de
Roland-Garros je crois que c'est un peu
que je vais pas dire que c'est comme ça
que Cyril a démarré je crois qu'il avait
fait deux trois choses avant mais c'est
ce qui lui a permis vraiment de voilà de
devenir ce qu'il est et il sait
l'affection et l'amitié que je lui porte
et je sais qu'il me la rend bien donc je
suis d'autant plus heureux d'être parmi
vous ce soir des anecdotes oui il y en a
plein on recevait sur plus c'était hyper
décontracté on se verra Raphaël Nadal on
a l'impression de le connaître depuis 40
ans et ça ça c'est vrai que au début au
début Cyril était un petit peu vous
savez il adore le tennis donc il était
un petit peu sur l'état de la réserve et
et après évidemment et je crois que son
défi était de jouer je crois d'échanger
des balles avec Rafael et je crois que
ça je crois que ça a été le cas alors je
vous épargne le score
on parle pas du score merci merci
beaucoup merci d'être venu